my job with Collider and I'm here with
the good folks behind villains I want to
give a huge thank you the only reason we
get to be at South by Southwest is
because of sponsors it's really
expensive to be here huge thank you del
Tesoro for being our sponsor tequila it
is it's good to drink first of all thank
you all so much for coming into the
studio I really sincerely appreciate it
I have to get I have to start with I'm a
big fan of your work and I've seen all
of Burn Notice and I'm just curious do
people still stop you all the time from
the show is it one of these things that
has sort of stayed with you
probably yeah more than any other any
other thing I've done and it's funny
because I think I've done nine movies
and another TV two other TV shows since
and it's always the first thing is like
Andrew the guy from Burn Notice and it's
great because I didn't know it basically
plays around the world now and and I
knew Netflix had it for a while now
Amazon has it so yeah it's it's just
living on beyond me I think they also
are surprised at how bad I look now
which is which is not surprising I
looked great then and I look horrible
now and that's fine but that's the
biggest surprise the thing I feel to a
lot of actors who when their shows start
going on streaming how it's it
completely opens up where you know all
these people are discovering things now
on Netflix or Amazon so it's like you
know a whole second life and people are
watching it it like you know there's
someone today it's starting but Burn
Notice for the first time and all of a
sudden binging all the seasons yeah yeah
that's that's definitely true I in fact
my own example as I watched Breaking Bad
on Netflix it was on him safe I didn't
even know that I mean that's I don't
know it's a Netflix show they're like no
it's it was on AMC I was like what Sam
City so yeah so uh you guys are here for
villains and everyone watching this
maybe two people have seen the movie by
the time someone's watching this so I
hate asking the generic question but
talk a little bit about what it's about
and if you don't mind who you play yeah
so villains is a dark comedy it's about
two amateur criminals that break into a
suburban home
and they find a little girl chained up
in the basement which does sound very
dark but it's a comedy it's fun and
basically they decide they're gonna help
this little girl but before they can do
that
the homeowners arrive home where this
sort of kind of affluent you know
buttoned up suburban couple and the
whole movie plays is the sort of power
struggle between these two couples in in
a single house and Jeff plays George who
is one of said homeowners and obviously
he's not happy to find these two you
know junkie drifters and in his home
I found that recently I've been
interviewing a lot of people that are
directing together writing together how
did you two actually meet and oh and of
course I have to ask what's the biggest
fight you had on set while making this
we met we were freshman year roommates
New York Universe and Emily assigned
yeah so Big Ups to the NYU bursar's
office for starting this creative
partnership and and yeah we just you
know we we were just best friends for
four years before we started to actually
work together and you know I think
that's kind of the special sauce and
what we do I think if we weren't close
if we weren't like brothers who could
get into arguments with one another and
be fine two seconds later it would be a
whole different story
you know people always ask us you know
what's it like directing on two of you
or whatever but that's the only way
we've ever worked so I think we would
sooner ask like well how do you direct
as one person you know like what how do
you know your ideas are good you know
how do you how do you how do you do that
without having that filter of that other
person that has that checks you you know
it eliminates the shittiest of ideas
right away I have somebody else to say
you know to stop it before it gets to
the world you got to a certain point to
where people won't say no to you and
what one when you're the director
sometimes you know I'm Jeff well but
like you know like and and and so you
get into this situation sometimes where
you can have a bad idea for a movie if
you made one successful movie you can
have a bad idea for a second one and
somebody might just give you give you
the money to make it and you go and you
do it just nobody ever says no to you
the whole time and you wind up making a
bad second
movie or something but you know I think
we always have somebody at you know the
highest level of the set that's a check
on you you know like I I need if I'm
gonna come up with something it's got to
be something that Dan wants to do too
and vice-versa so sorry second part of
the question was our biggest fight on
set yeah we try to get him out before
hand yeah I don't know if there were a
ton on set where we went back and forth
I'm gonna stop you there sure yeah is
that our answer probably no III actually
never saw them them fight they would
have you know definitely some very
passionate discussions and I'm not
downplaying by saying that that they
were really heated for what they were
trying to get after and just like we
were saying they were basically checking
each other but I do remember one
particular day I think I had to speak
for four pages like 8:00 and and and
yeah maybe pages I've blocked it out and
and they they both came on but
separately usually it's one stays at the
monitor and the other comes and gives
notes but what happened was Bobby came
over and gave me like eight notes and
then he left and then Dan came over and
gave me like seven notes and then they
walked away and I think Kyra goes I
think they just gave you 15 notes but
they don't know that yeah that's
basically just we're very easy to work
with well that was the incredible part
of working with with these four actors
was just how you know how professional
everybody is and how I mean especially
Jeff and Kyra you know having been
number one on the call sheet on these
gigantic shows for four years like we
were just we learned so much you know
working with them and seeing that like
like that that anecdote ended with him
taking 15 notes and nailing all of them
you know what I mean so it was just it
was a it was a pretty special experience
working with you know bona fide movie
stars I'm the four leads in this movie
are all very talented actors and it's
hard to have you know everyone there's a
lot of competition I'm curious what
compromising photos you have to get all
four of them in a movie together
that's compromising photos of ourselves
that we yeah right exactly yeah and
maybe came complicit in the absence
sending about will do it yeah stop
sending them but talk a little bit about
putting together this cast and and
Geoffrey what was it about the script in
the project that said I want to do this
sure so yeah I mean that the the casting
process was it was it was we looked at
we had very very specific sort of
stipulations for each of these roles so
it you know there wasn't this enormous
list of people that we we could pull
from that would make Bobby and I happy
and I think that the first the first
actor we got on was Bill skarsgård and
and Mickey was a challenge for us
because we really wanted this character
to have this kind of life like dancer
like sort of physicality and this like
this charisma that that you know we kind
of wanted him to feel like this sort of
like this 90s heartthrob type thing and
we really weren't finding that and then
one of our producers suggested bill
skarsgård who we really hadn't
considered and obviously it was very hot
you know with penny wise you know it had
just been kind of this smash and we
Skype with him and he was incredibly
down-to-earth and and really passionate
about the material and so we brought him
on and that kind of opened the
floodgates and you know very very lucky
to get Michael Monroe interested in the
script actually when Bobby and I wrote
this script in 2015 we had just seen it
follows and we were like Michael Munroe
is perfect for this but like you know we
sort of yeah we told the to all the
producers we were interested in that and
they were like maybe go [ __ ] yourself
you're not gonna get my coming around
right now but then two years later just
kind of came back around because she has
the same age in his bill so or
compromising photos yes exactly and we
revealed the compromising photos and
then for Jeff in here I mean we were in
love with Jeff's work in Fargo season
two it was just like when we saw that
character we were like oh because Jorge
kind of has to do this thing where he's
straddling making you laugh and sort of
terrifying you and there's a
surprisingly small amount of actors in
Hollywood that can do that and genuinely
do it where you're really still alive
yeah we first Skyped with with Jeff I
was just blown away by his ability to
articulate the tone of the movie but
we right away you know like it was
always this type of thing where we knew
that it was this that it was a little
outside of the box a little strange you
know funny but dark and and you know the
way that he put it saying that it you
know operates kind of just south of
farce was it kind of became our rallying
cry for for how we you know built that
the tone of this movie and it was and he
was kind of like a coal architect in
that so it was and and and it and
because Jeff and Kier are these
incredibly experienced actors like on
set we needed they needed to have a
really strong grasp of that tone because
we needed them to be sort of
quarterbacks while while working with
with the other actors and so we were
just so lucky to have that in Jeff and
kira-kira it was the same sort of way
where she just instantly got who that
who Gloria was you know we always talked
about Gloria as being this sort of
Tennessee Williams esque character
that's like plucked out of one of his
plays and thrown into this movie and she
does it's like kind of very Blanche
DuBois like quality about her and one of
the first things Kyra said to us was
this character reminds me of something
out of Tennessee Williams oh my god this
is this is it you know and and to have
to have them like Dan said on set
quarterbacking the tone like it's a
scary thing sometimes to ask actors to
really go for it and play in a slightly
heightened world because if you [ __ ] it
you mess that up it's it's it's it can
be embarrassing you know like if you're
if you're really going for it and the
movie turns out to be a stinker like you
can look like more of a fool than if you
just did you know maybe like a family
drama that didn't turn out so well at
least you on-screen weren't you know
taking all these chances and making a
fool of yourself like we were asking
them to potentially do so it was yeah it
was very special you know what they said
was true that it's a very specific tone
and it's not really out there it's and a
lot of my choices I like to do things
that one challenge challenge me in ways
that I haven't done you know up till now
and the other is hmm Kenna can I pull it
off you know there there are roles and
there
projects where I was like oh I could I
could do this this is not something
that's out of my comfort zone or I've
done before and this is something I had
never done on screen before just like
they said it's it's just just shy of
farce but the stakes are so high and the
circumstances of of what the plot is
about about these kids who are villains
who stumble upon a house and what what
is seemingly just a old doting couple
turn into even worse villains than them
and to see that evolution and that
psychology and somehow somehow bring
hopefully humor to it was I knew it was
going to be a big challenge and that's
and then having Skyped with them and
they agreed that this is the tone we're
going for it I knew I'd want to do it
just to see like I said can we pull it
off
one of the things about the movie is
that it primarily takes place in one
location which is obviously a budgetary
thing as well as I mean the fact is it's
at one location
do you as an actor do you prefer working
that kind of thing where you're it's
like that one location or do you know
what I mean and also talk a little bit
about the fact that you know it is just
one location and when was it written
that way because you're thinking yeah I
mean one location it doesn't for me it
didn't matter I mean it's you just knew
where you're going to work every day
really you know and what's interesting
also about the house was because you
worked in the house every day and they
these characters were trapped in the
house literally and then we were trapped
as actors figuratively having going
there every day there was a certain
monotony and there was a certain
craziness to just being there every
single day for a month and a half that
you know I probably helped the film in
someone yeah as far as the you know the
the impetus for the single location
Bobby and I our first feature is a movie
called body and that also takes place 95
percent in a single home in a mansion
and a sort of lesson that we learned
making that movie which was a total
shoestring budget 11 night shoot was 11
consecutive overnights
$50,000 also kind of went lost our minds
a little bit the crew in this single
house but you know after the dust is
settled we kind of realized that because
we own that location and we left our
lights up we left all the gear up we
could walk away from a set up but you
know 7:00 p.m. one one night and come
back in at 6 a.m. the next morning and
just start there you know you're not
burning two hours at the head and tail
of every day loading and unloading out
so we got you know whatever it was 25 30
percent more shooting to actual shooting
time and so our 11-day shoot felt more
like 15 days so when we sat down to
write this script we were like we think
that we haven't yet grown out of this
why don't we do it in one location again
and and you know that way we can really
stretch that was going to be something
that proved to be such a positive the
first time and we kind of just do the
bigger version of that and you know and
really now our horizons are expanding
we're talking about the next movie maybe
not even being in a house you know it
might be on a on a boat or in a hospital
it might even be more than one location
I said we'll see I got to tell you I
didn't even think about that that that
extra time you get for not unloading and
loading I mean that 11 days it was like
15 days and especially with these are
movies that are you know they're they're
they're they're chatty there's a very
very performance dependent you know and
and their least these two have been you
know very monologue II I mean like Jeff
said there we made these you made these
actors you know do a lot of lines and so
you want to have the time to do a couple
more takes than you would otherwise like
it would it would be potentially lethal
to the project to have to rush through
and only be able to get one take of you
know a huge line or a huge chunk of a
monologue or something so that actually
those you know those extra couple hours
really really do kind of save your ass
like you know company moves or what kill
you you know and that's like that's the
number one thing that that's the piece
of advice that we pass on to you know
other filmmakers whoever asked us like
you know what what if what have we done
that it's worked where do we start it's
like I'm like Bryson that takes place in
one space so that you can actually you
know court so I mean it goes without
saying but I'm saying if you're if
you're putting this together from just
like plucking out of yours
savings are asking your grandmother to
like you know give you 10 grand because
you want to make a short like if you can
keep the locations down that's more time
that you have to actually shoot the film
you know so those logistical restraints
often lead to like creative gems you
know like we find that I mean maybe
we're just optimists but we find that
you you make discoveries and stuff when
you kind of remove all the other
variables and the other spectacle and
it's just like putting four actors or
two actors or whatever it in a room and
give yourself that that's that's the Box
you have to operate in and then you'll
you know you find ways to find a magic
in that I've spoken to a lot of
filmmakers that say the limitations are
what really helped the creative process
but everyone who comes through when we
do lounges like this or studios at
locations we like to do something called
get to know in this place it's gonna be
get to know yourself by Southwest
attendee I promise these are harmless
questions a little bit out of the box
what TV show would you love to guest
star on and what TV show would you guys
like to guest write and direct you know
I it's it's no longer on but I would
have cut my left arm off to be on veep I
loved that show I loved the writing
ianucci created just such a great satire
and I'm a huge fan of his and and Julia
I would have loved to just share the
screen with her if now if I caught a
choice right now it'd be guest on VP
yeah that's yeah I mean I yeah sure just
what I'm watching right now I don't know
if this is my whole life I might have
liked other TV more but I just finished
Russian doll and I just love anything
it's like a sort of a genre blend that's
like you know sci-fi but with a heart
with like sort of like you know this
kind of a love story this humanity at
the core of it I just that's like that's
like our bread and butter like we love
that type of stuff so yeah it would not
mind should there be a season to to to
do that if anyone's watching that'd be
great yeah I'm gonna go with the good
place it's just like it's just such a
nice sweet environment to be in and I
feel like a nice time yeah like Jim you
with like with those actors and in that
you know the the way that that show just
kind of manages to be like very
mainstream but also really high concept
I always just think it's a kind of it's
in a unique space I think it's really
funny
the writers on that show are really
incredible completely agree do you guys
have a favorite sci-fi or fantasy film I
always go back to and it's it's
everyone's list is aliens it's alien you
know really sketch one yeah alien not
with us what I talked about one set I
mean you know just and what he did in
the horror and the fear and I just saw
it was it was something like 40 years
ago 77 she's unbelievable on that and
it's still it's still to mine it's still
like it was about ten years ago in my
mind
yeah well it's a masterclass in how you
reveal the monster you know and yeah and
what you don't show I would probably say
I hope it counts but Brazil I think it's
like just one of my favorite movies and
I think that there's like you know
nothing more terrifying than that kind
of dystopian future ism you know I love
just I'm a sucker for all that stuff so
yeah I'm gonna go you know whatever
comes on makes me feel good neverending
story that's a great just a great feel
good fantasy film come on of course that
the David Bowie I'm sorry it's actually
a legend but it's about course fine I
don't have to like sit here example a is
there anything that you guys collect I
don't so much collect it anymore
but I got a couple of decks Magic the
Gathering cards those that's my jam back
in the day I still got a couple for
surrounds fiancee is gonna be happy I I
have a small collection of vintage
cameras which I guess is a little bit
cliche filmmaker to have but I my wife
and I had a baby eight months ago and I
needed to make space so I threw about
half of them away yeah but now yeah I'm
I'm just I'm getting rid of him I'm
collecting free space that the cameras
used to use to occupy so yeah do you
remember your first movie or TV show
crush
Molly Ringwald Breakfast Club I think
probably one of the biggest ones was
Natalie Portman and and Star Wars
Episode one like why'd it really really
stuck with me though and I became like
this huge Natalie Portman freak well
yeah it's funny it wasn't until under a
blanket the entire time I know what
they're saying that's the worst part I
understand I think by the way you know I
think Keira Knightley was one of the
doubles so oh yeah yep Assad one of Star
Wars Natalie Portman say episode is like
a TV man so Star Wars has episodes like
one through nine and Episode one was the
Phantom Menace and Padme was like she
had decoys on the plane and they're in
the midst of a trade war scary he's like
I didn't sign up for this let me go
we're due 20 minutes on the Gungans it
was I think Sandra Bullock and what's
the one that she's a hacker lose it with
Ryan right yeah yeah where she's got the
really chunky laptop yeah sure and speed
though oh that's yeah it was we went on
a tangent on this one yeah what TV show
have you watched all the way through
more than once
Breaking Bad all the way through more
than once Arrested Development and the
British office there's good well I guess
not all the way through it's not done
but I have recently re-watched Game of
Thrones just because it's not clear from
the falkor the luckdragon correction I'm
rather nerdy when it comes to this stuff
but yeah have you ever seen Game of
Thrones three kids I could tell like the
face he's like all right yeah the kids
are too young for gaming
no but did you see the episode of Dora
the Explorer the other guys
because who saw that coming unbeliev
I've got three under six so there isn't
there isn't like hours and hours of
streaming my hobbies is some good
television though my children have
learned we have the remote where you can
talk into it right you know and so you
can say like Mickey Mouse Clubhouse or
you know or you could say Game of
Thrones but that has not been said and
so but it's it's funny to hear them go
like door door ice paw Doris what and
you see these odd titles come up you
know like Sin City and like no did you
mean Salo
professional no how did they get the
professional out of Dora the Explorer
now playing Caligula one of my last
things for you guys everyone I'm always
curious how people got interested in the
entertainment industry like what made
you become an actor want to be an actor
what made you want to go to NYU to study
filmmaking do you remember what it was
as a kid or was it a performance poverty
it's a big motivator it's it's very true
and I don't know how to instill that on
my children like just like get on the
porch and sleep out there and I'm not
gonna feed you for four days no I that's
not going to happen you know I actually
didn't know and it's gonna sound weird I
didn't know acting was a profession when
I was growing up I watched it on TV and
I was you know I was a big fan of like
Jimmy Stewart and and I'd be watching
his movie and he'd be yelling Barry
where are the kids and I'd be like going
God you know he's so great and then I'd
see him at the premiere of some sort of
thing with the bad guy like mr. Potter I
mean how can they be friendless
for all that after all the things he did
to you why are you smiling and hugging
him documentaries alright and then I was
24 at the time no I was a young guy I
mean was a kid and I didn't I didn't it
didn't make sense to me I but I knew I
wanted to do that I wanted to make up
voices and characters and I would
perform for my family and my friends and
and then so it was you know was very
early on but it was a such an odd thing
to go wait a minute you're gonna pay me
to do this this is like the best best
job ever
I get paid not in their film but I got
paid things yeah I think like probably
my the earliest thing I think is
probably just like playing with action
figures as a little boy and just you
know you have what I would just have
these like you know these like elaborate
backstories and it was always like this
but that had nothing to do with the the
the you know the comic book universe is
that they came from I would just kind of
like you know make up who these people
were and had this like saga that I would
just pick back up every time I took the
toys out and I think that was the first
time that there was ever like a creation
of a story and and been my brain you
know what I mean III think that the my
introduction to like to physical
filmmaking
was a little bit like less sort of like
poetic I I think it was sort of actually
like unlike the technology or the
software side like I was into computers
from a very young age and my you know I
was on the family computer all the time
and then you know when I was and when it
when it was whatever it was final cut
like version 1 what you know the super
super early clunky stuff like I kind of
like somehow stumbled upon that and
started learning like the Edit editing
software when I was in like eighth grade
and and yeah I kind of like figured out
that this medium existed and that like
storytelling was something that I kind
of was drawn to and then by the time I
was you know 15 I was like I know what I
want to do with my life and I just sort
of like proceeded from there and you
know the rest was kind of history and
because we go back and like look at the
you know because we didn't know each
other until college but you go back and
look at the films that we made with our
friends in high school it's remarkable
how how similar
how dumb they are yeah but you know a
lot of people have that experience I
think yeah so I don't know just kind of
work that way on that note I'm gonna say
congratulations on being part of South
by Southwest you thank you so much for
coming in the studio and I wish you guys
nothing but the best thanks so much for
having us appreciate it